how does the time reset actually work
why are they called mimics here are the
answers to your biggest questions about
Edge of Tomorrow in the film's opening
Montage we learned that a meteor has
crashed to Earth bringing with it an
invasive extraterrestrial species that
humans call mimics they've been
spreading across Europe for years easily
overcoming all conventional military
defenses to combat this alien menace the
world's governments join together to
form the United Defense Force or UDF and
begin manufacturing suits of powered
armor for their infantry when the UDF
has their first victory at the Battle of
Verdun the belief is that the new Mech
suits have proven their worth after all
Sergeant Rita vitasky was able to use
one to perform incredible and daring
Feats despite limited experience proving
that anyone with minimal training can
operate one efficiently with a new
jacket technology and limited amount of
training we've been able to create super
soldiers in actuality Rita's apparently
instant Mastery of the armor and the
battlefield were the result of her
ability to repeat any day in which she
dies giving her unlimited replay plays
of any deadly scenario since the UDF is
unaware of this and refuse to believe it
in any of Rita's previous lives they
move forward confidently with an
aggressive invasion of France operation
downfall however Rita and her Ally Dr
Carter suspect there's still another
layer to the Battle of Verdun they
believe that the mimics eventually
allowed the UDF to win at Verdun in
order to lend them a false sense of
confidence prompting an all-out assault
that would allow the mimics to
annihilate the UDF in a single stroke
it's also possible that the mimics
accepted the result of the battle of
Verdun that ended with Rita losing her
ability to reset deciding that this was
Victory enough
throughout the story of Edge of Tomorrow
the shape-shifting alien menace that's
conquering Earth is always referred to
as the mimics it's a cool sounding name
that helps to uniquify the film's
villain avoiding the constant reuse of
the words alien or enemy however
although the mimics do look and move in
a strange ever-changing way it's never
exactly clear who or what it is they're
mimicking to find an answer to this
question you'd have to go back to the
source material the light novel all you
need is killed by Hiroshi and sakurasaka
there it's explained that the aliens
based their Earthly shape on the first
life form they encountered after crash
landing on our planet a starfish this
idea isn't really represented in the
film with the mimics receiving a totally
original design that doesn't map easily
onto anything in our Animal Kingdom
their forms are constantly changing
their metallic tentacles forming into
legs or sharp spikes or unraveling so
they can rest flat in the dirt beneath
their prey since the mimics bodies are
incredibly fast and perpetually
reshaping themselves the audience rarely
gets a good long look at them ironically
this makes them one of the more
interesting and memorable alien designs
in recent memory since we get an idea as
to what they look like but would
struggle to describe them to another
person starfish doesn't really cut it
and neither does any other comparison
mimic we'll have to do when cage rescues
Sergeant Rita vitrovsky on the
battlefield demonstrating a clear
foreknowledge of the dangers around them
Rita realizes that he must be on a Time
Loop find me when you wake up in his
next life cage finds Rita and learns
that months earlier she also absorbed
the blood of an alpha mimic gaining the
ability to start the day over upon her
death however she lost that ability on
her last Loop during which she managed
to win the Battle of Verdun but also
suffered a serious non-lethal blood loss
when she received a transfusion of new
normal blood she lost the ability to
reset the day upon hearing this we can't
help but ask one logical question how
can Rita possibly know that she no
longer resets time when she dies unless
she died and didn't come back this
unfortunately is something the viewer
simply has to accept in order for the
movie to work to patch up this potential
plot hole we're forced to accept that
Rita and a later cage can simply feel
that their ability to reset time is gone
we see it happen to cage after he
suffers his own similar injury and blood
transfusion in the final Loop of the
film is it beyond belief that mimic
Alphas would have such a sixth sense
that allows them to know whether or not
they're detached from the time stream
not entirely one can imagine that such
an instinct might have evolved within
mimics in order to alert an alpha that
it's lost its metaphysical Save State
still it's certainly convenient for Our
Heroes and for the audience Dr Carter
does a pretty solid job of explaining
the mechanics of edge of tomorrow's time
travel during his initial meeting with
cage While most mimics are of the
animalistic Soldier variety there are
two special kinds of mimic that together
give them their unique advantage over
Humanity their movements are governed by
a massive
Omega mimic a strange and stationary
creature with the power to skip
backwards in time by about one day
however the Omega can only do this when
it's counterpart the alpha mimic is
killed this is basically a defensive
reflex while the Omega remains hidden
the alpha goes into battle if the alpha
is killed that means a battle has not
gone as well as possible and should be
attempted again with the benefit of this
experience in short the mimics are saves
coming the war for earth when cage is
infused with the Alpha's Blood on the
battlefield he acquires the Alpha's
ability to trigger the omega's time
reset the Omega is still the one
altering time but its reflex is kicked
every time cage dies instead of wind the
alpha dies cage gets the added benefit
of countless replays and accumulated
experience giving him an advantage in
battle like Rita before him cage only
loses this power once enough of his
blood has been replaced because of the
mimics activities and motivations are
kept a mystery from the audience we
never definitively learn what effect
Cage's blood infusion has on the mimic's
own abilities whether or not the Alpha's
death would still trigger a time reset
while cage has the power is never
totally clear since we don't see an
alpha killed between the first and final
versions of operation downfall however
since the mimic's behavior remains
predictable in the time Loop we can
safely assume that they're not retaining
Knowledge from each reset the only
changing factor is Cage's psychic
Visions from the Omega which grow
stronger after each Loop this is how the
mimics eventually figure out that cage
has become the new reset trigger setting
a trap for him with a fake vision of the
omega's location in this Loop the mimic
Alpha Corners cage and deliberately
keeps him from killing himself
apparently trying to capture him alive
so as not to lose this progress cage
manages to reset anyway and the mimics
never seem to pay special attention to
him again this implies that they only
know know of his unique nature on Loops
in which he gives it away before their
final charge towards the Omega during
their final Loop Rita and cage share a
brief moment during which Rita commends
cage on his bravery during their work
together just before charging into
battle Rita kisses cage on the lips
saying that she wishes she'd gone to
know him better it's not totally
unreasonable to think that Rita might
just want a Last Kiss Before Dying
especially when the available willing
partner is a fellow soldier who looks
like Tom Cruise however the moment Rings
a little false when you consider that
while cage has known Rita for years
through the repetition of the time Loop
Rita has only known cage for about a day
and a half true there have been Loops
during which cage and Rita have grown
close over the course of a long road
trip but even then Rita remains an
emotionally guarded person who hesitates
to let herself feel for cage because
each Loop implies the repetition of some
but not all of the routines that cage
and Frida follow on their usual paths we
actually don't see very much of cage and
this version of Rita so this is is one
of the reasons why the kiss races some
eyebrows in an sa4 the wire film critic
Esther Zuckerman described the last
second romantic twist to be a betrayal
of the character for the sake of
offering cage a reward for his personal
growth over the course of the film
indeed the moment plays as if it's more
about demonstrating that cage is no
longer the loathsome unlovable weasel
that we meet at the start of the film
than it is about Rita learning to trust
again
as previously mentioned the film is
based on a novel by Hiroshi sakuruzaka
entitled all you need is kill according
to an interview with variety Warner
Brothers president of marketing sucral
found that audiences were put off by
movies with the word kill in the title
leading to the Project's rebranding
director Doug Lyman on the other hand
later told den of geek that the film was
renamed to accommodate the film's tone
which is significantly lighter than that
of the source material he suggested that
the film be renamed Live Die Repeat
instead someone at Warner Brothers
wasn't fond of this title and bequeathed
the project the more generic sounding
title Edge of Tomorrow against lyman's
objections Live Die Repeat was used as a
tagline for the movie instead Lyman
feels that this contributed to the film
underperforming at the box office
despite critical Acclaim someone must
have listened because when the movie was
released on home video months later
lived I repeat was suddenly the larger
print on the box and digital
marketplaces listed the full title as
Live Die Repeat edge of tomorrow
depending on when you purge just a
physical copy of the movie it may
feature the two titles in a different
order Doug Lyman said that the sequel's
working title is live die repeat repeat
and that its release would canonize Live
Die Repeat as the title of the first
film
once cage has lost the ability to reset
time he and Rita lead a suicide mission
to destroy the Omega which is hidden
under the luva Museum in Paris their
mission is successful as cage is able to
drop a belt of live grenades into the
omega's mouth cage and the alpha are
caught in the blast as well and it
appears that cage lives long enough to
absorb some of their blood then he wakes
up at an earlier point in the timeline
than he's accustomed to before his
disgraceful demotion to private and
learns that the mimics have lost their
capacity to fight the war instead of a
bloody trench battle operation downfall
will now be met with minimal resistance
from the Extraterrestrial Menace this
seems awfully convenient for cage who is
now saved not only the world but his own
career and reputation the film didn't
give us a clear explanation as to why
this has happened but we can extrapolate
one from the logic of the film it may be
that cage absorbing the omega's blood
has a different effect than just
absorbing the alphas giving him more
control over the time stream than he had
as merely the trigger for the reset he
may have instinctively selected a moment
in time to return to that would put him
in the best possible position
co-screenwriter Christopher Macquarie
promised in a since deleted tweet that
the sequel will concretely answer this
question I'll see you tomorrow arguably
one of the biggest points of confusion
surrounding Edge of Tomorrow was why it
wasn't really considered a hit before
the film was even released the Press was
already prepared to right off edge of
tomorrow as a flop whether this is the
fault of the generic sounding title or
the marketing campaign's failure to
convey the high concept is still up for
debate in any case Edge of Tomorrow
opened at number three at the box office
losing the weekend to the tear-jerking
romance The Fault in Our Stars and the
live-action Disney Fantasy Maleficent
the film grossed about 100 million
dollars at the U.S box office and
another 270 million dollars overseas but
its reported budget was 178 million
dollars it's also worth noting that
projecting Edge of Tomorrow to be a
failure fit into a popular narrative
that Tom Cruz's star was fading in the
United States his previous three films
Oblivion Jack Reacher and Rock of Ages
were all considered to have
underperformed domestically so it's
possible that the atmosphere around the
film's release was already poisoned
[Music]